[Music]
on February 2021 we published a video on
this channel calling out the famous
investor Kathy Wood at the time everyone
and their mom thought Kathy was an
investing genius her investment from Ark
and its ETS were going up and up and up
with $60 billion of the massive money in
it and her claim the fame was pitching
herself as this genius Tech investor by
making these stupidly wild predictions
about how Tesla was going to go this
high or how this Tech stock was going to
go this high this stock is heading for
$7,000 over the next 5 years is very
high and the longer the base you say 5
years the longer the base you know that
the bigger the breakout at 7,000 Plus
versus 1900 now we're still well above
that and how the future is going to be
so bright and how we're all going to get
riched together by investing in these
tech stocks that are going to change the
world think kind of Warren Buffett but
for the GameStop Reddit generation Kathy
Wood sees the future before the street
does and it works Kathy Wood was able to
make outage everyday people feel like
they had a real shot of getting rich if
they just bought into her ETF an ETF
that she collects insane fees from no
matter if it goes up or crashes into the
ground when Lambo but in that old video
we made back in February 2021 me and our
expert guest Arvid Ali saw right through
her shade in that old video we exposed
that Kathy Wood was not some tech
investing genius she doesn't even have a
background attack so one is she doesn't
know anything about Technology based on
her background there isn't a single
point of indication that she understands
the first thing about any piece of
technology then she also points to her
analysts being industry insiders in all
these different Industries again I
looked at all their LinkedIn profiles
they have uh about as much expertise in
in any of these Technologies as the
average Reddit users again I don't
really see how her stock portfolio is
any better than the average 12-year-olds
and at the end of this video Arvid made
a buold prediction and as soon as they
get everyone's money they collect as
many fees as they can and very quickly
the performance of that ETF uh largely
underperforms the rest of the market so
typically you'll see like a big uh big
wave up and a big wave down and that's
right he predicted that Ark would
collapse and in his video that he posted
on his channel also in February 2021 he
predicted that Ark would Collapse by 80
to 90% by comparing to past was stre
skines that it look like she copy from
what happened with Guru Gerald sii's
Innovation fund ultimately his investors
lost 90% of their money so what happened
to Janice once the 1990s Tech bubble
finally burst their fund
lost up to
84% of their investor money and we were
shocked by the HTE comments we got I
like Kathy Kathy is amazing for us
people like Kathy are a safe her
operation is legitimate trustworthy
genuine up Kathy she's so trans one
thing
[Music]
k% I can keep my Kathy will will go down
in history as one of the best fun
managers of all time well then let's see
if Kathy Wood did indeed go down as one
of the best fund managers of all time oh
would you look at that exactly as arv
predicted Arc reached its peak price the
month we posted that video and then it
collapsed by 80% today Arc is still down
by around 70% which is a nice way of
saying that Miss Kathy Wood over here
took $60 billion of the life savings of
average everyday Americans gambled it on
a bunch of risky tech stocks that she
knew wasn't going to work and then
inevitably lost almost all of it and
then guess what thanks to the way her
fee structure was set up she didn't
experience any of these losses no she
walked away Scot Frey with something
like $250 million of your money you lost
almost everything while she is now a
quarter of a billionaire and unlike
people like Elizabeth Holmes and S
bigman freed who really bad at
committing fraud today no one is mad at
Kathy for anything no lawsuits no hates
no one even knows they got got but Jake
I mean the entire Market has been
sideways no RIS no worry right maybe she
really did believe that these Tech TOS
were going to go to the moon at least
she's in the arena trying stuff can we
really know that she had bad intense
just listen to her talk she sounds like
a nice caring Mom it's not her fault
right well actually yes it is her fault
because this exact same scheme sheep
pull off has been done over and over and
over again since the 1950s there have
been a lot of these Cathy wood type
figures specifically the most famous one
was Gerald Sai and then there have been
other uh individuals and institutions
that have done this but every single
time they run this Playbook of claiming
that they're the next genius who can
really pick stocks and specifically they
can pick these stocks that align
themselves to a future Technologies and
they're going to make you billions of
dollars by doing this they always have
their funds go down by up to 90% And
it's been happening over and over again
and by the way arvet Ali is the former
president of Jordan velers companies yes
the real Wolf of Wall Street he's the
adviser that celebrities pro athletes
and billionaires go to when they want
help growing their income and he
graduated with a degree in mathematics
at the age of 19 from UCLA and he also
went to law school today he's also an
advisor to a US State Attorney General
and that's why he's not scared to call
out people like Kathy Wood I'm not
scared because I have a law background
but more importantly you know they know
full well they'll have to be subject to
Discovery meaning all their emails and
text messages of both themselves and all
their employees will be revealed if they
ever went into a legally contentious
situation because I it's very easy to
prove that a single sentence one time
was made with an intention to defraud
simply because they knew that they were
lying which is why he was the only
person that was able to see through her
charade all the way back in 2021 see
Everyone likes to hate on the obvious
Gamers who get caught Elizabeth holes
and bman freed and so on but the truth
is that these people are the worst at
scamming because they got caught they're
sloppy they're not good at committing
fraud
the people who get caught are actually
pretty bad at fraud they don't have a
good end game they didn't think this
true they don't really know how to trick
people they just kind of you know get
excited create some hype but they have
no idea what they're doing but the more
sophisticated fraudsters are the people
who never get into any sort of trouble
like Kathy would which means Kathy one
of the best of them all tens of billions
lost and yet she's still a multi-
multi-millionaire and yet no one is up
in arms and now it looks like she's
trying to do it all over again and
that's why we're making this video and
you know what the real nail on the
coffin is that we just found out is that
Kathy was his mentor is none other than
Bill Hong ah yes you might remember Bill
Hong as the disgrace fund manager of Aro
Capital Management that lost $20 billion
in Just 2 days and still walked away
with all his fees just like his Mente
Kathy it was fraud and then got indicted
on fraud and racketeering the Wang along
with aragos CFO were charged by federal
prosecutors with racketeering conspiracy
Securities fraud and wire fraud this is
the guy that provided the C capital for
Kathy's ETFs after all if I wanted to
rip off the public this would be the
only Mentor I would want stay dangerous
subscribe for more and let's get into
it if you've been hurt by a giant
Corporation then you have to sue them
because not only do they have plenty of
money to pay you but suing them is the
only way to keep them in check the
problem is suing costs a lot of money
but luckily that is where this law firm
called Morgan and Morgan comes in with
Morgan and Morgan you only pay if they
win your case that means you can take on
these powerful people without having to
spend a single dollar out of pockets all
you got to do is go to for people.com
train with the link below you can submit
your case in eight clicks or lets
without ever having to leave your chair
and that's it Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury law firm and
they are good they recently won a giant
case against 3M that could top $ 122.5
billion over the years and much much
more but aside from the money this
picture really sums out what they're all
about they've got 100 offices all across
America and over 800 expert lawyers that
deal in all types of cases from car
accidents to negligence to class action
losses to workplace discrimination but
because they only get paid if they wion
they do have to be selective about the
cases they bring on so pause the video
scroll down and click the link below to
go to for.com Tren to submit your case
now thanks to Morgan and Morgan for
sponsoring this
video Kathy Wood and Bill Hong met each
other at church one day and immediately
hit it off they both shared the belief
that they could rely on their faith to
help them out with business decisions
how sweet right wouldn't you want your
money manager relying on their faith see
Billa turned $200 million into a 20
billion fortune that may build one of
the richest men on the planet except
this Empire was built on a house of
cards a house of cards of risky bets and
5 to1 leverage that's why in Just 2 days
he lost $20 billion it was the fastest
implosion in the history of Finance yet
despite losing all his clients money and
his company becoming one of the greatest
Financial failures of all time Bill
still walked away a very very rich man
his former employees said that even
though their bank accounts were
completely wiped out when aragos went
under Bill wag is still likely a
billionaire through his personal
investment and holdings like the seed
money he put into Ark Bill hang's
collapse came in early 2021 but it was
but a preview for what was to come for
his men Kathy Wood see what happened to
Bill Wong and Kathy Wood is the only
possible outcome when you run this
Playbook of getting people to invest in
technology which brings us to step
number one don't have a technology
background see you would think that in
order to know what tech stocks are going
to blow up next it would help if you
know you had a background in Tech maybe
engineering maybe in AI you know all the
things that Kathy Hypes up but no arford
pulled up for LinkedIn back in February
2021 in his video and would you look at
that no has the leader Kathy spent one
day working in Tech or science in her
entire life no since then Kathy would
has wiped her lengthed and clean so now
it only says Arc with zero Tech
experience that means she is just a pure
Wall Street Predator through and through
she started as a fun manager at Alliance
Bernstein an investment firm managing $5
billion in assets at Alliance Bernstein
she made the mind-blowing achievement of
a
0.81% annual investment return rate for
our clients over the span of 10 years
yes that is rights she got less than a
1% annual return rate from 2001 to 2011
sounds pretty genius to me but think
about it at least she still got to pay
her her 3% annual fee that she happily
took why don't the basement dwelling
clubs realize this well Kathy has one
skill that you must Master the art of
fake graphs and deceptive numbers yes
like our savior Kathy you must only
showcase your fake theoretical gains in
a pretty graph and hide the fact that
your fees took away from most of your
clients profits in the fine print a
later analysis of her record lir found
her Investments to be highly volatile
and produce underwhelming long-term
results End quotes in other words Kathy
took super risky bets that didn't really
pay off kind of like today one of her
colleagues said that Kathy was viewed as
brilliant but also not institutional
that's why Kathy decided that she didn't
want to be part of the institution
anymore she wanted to do anything she
pleased with her client's money on her
own terms so just as things were going
sour between Kathy and her employer in
2012 something magical happened
according to her she was sitting
completely alone in her home on a
pictures day in August her three kids
were all away at camp and it was there
in that complete science that she
received what she called a Divine
calling from the Holy Spirit end quote
well I really feel that was the Holy
Spirit just saying to me okay this is
the plan end quote so at age 57 she
followed God's instructions and that is
a story behind behind her creating Arc I
mean this Arc that was the origin story
of The Genius Tech investor now doing
something this ambitious may sound hard
but luckily for Kathy she had just the
frosters the
[Music]
model say hello to Gerald side Gerald
side was basically the Kathy Wood of the
50s and 60s except he was way more
successful than his future people
because Jos side became a billionaire
doing this see in the late 50s and 60s
Gerald s pitched himself as this genius
Tech investor that started an aggressive
growth fund in 1958 under Fidelity
Investments he would later create the
Manhattan fund another aggressive growth
fund in 1965 where he would hype up the
tech stocks of the time like Xerox and
the Polaroid Corporation but by 1968
Gerald side sold his interest in the
funds I guess he didn't believe in the
future anymore and would you look at
that a year later in 1969 the funds
collapsed by 90% And was josai affected
by this collapse no he would still die
as a the billionaire sound familiar well
it should because this is also what
happened in the '90s during the Doom
bubble with another growth fund called
Janice that also lost everyone's money
while the fund managers walked away Rich
so with these role models in hand it was
now Kathy's turn to fool the Next
Generation it was 2012 when she had her
divine intervention and by that time
there was already a brand new generation
of investors that weren't around to get
burned during the Doom bubble a brand
new generation that would be the perfect
Mark for the future which brings us to
step number two give the cabs a sense of
meaning see all of us especially today
when God is dead all yearn for a sense
of meaning for us as a purpose and that
is the void that Kathy tapped into Kathy
tapped into that thing inside all of us
that wants to believe in a brighter
future she made us believe that
investing our money with her wouldn't
just make us rich but it will also
contribute to something bigger than
ourselves that we would be helping
transform the world AI eradicating
poverty space travel you could be part
of this and get rich at the same time
and this message went viral you can see
the glimmer in the plb's eyes now and
once you fool everyone into parting with
their life savings it's time to move on
to the next step making a ton of insane
predictions until one of them randomly
turns out to be
[Music]
true her first major claim to fame was
her Tesla stock prediction a yes it was
2014 everyone knew about Tesla stock
already but she predicted that Tesla
stock was soon Skyrocket along with a
ton of other predictions that all turned
out to be wrong that everyone forgot
about at the time Tesla was ark's
largest holding many people pointed out
that her previous stock Traditions have
flopped but when confronted with this
criticism Kathy simply said quote the
truth will wi out end quote and that
truth came in 2021 when Tesla stocks
started going crazy and suddenly her
stock predition seemed to be coming true
on January 7th 2021 Tesla hit that
$4,000 Mark a whole 2 years ahead of her
prediction when you account for the 5
to1 stock split that happened shortly
before
on top of that Kathy saw some the best
returns in the history of money
management in 2020 you're having one of
the best years in the history of
professional money management
catapulting her into one of the most
talked about celebrities in the
investment World suddenly this religious
lady everyone thought was crazy maybe
was a genius and just like that people
were yellowing their life savings into
Ark and this is pretty crazy to think
about a lady making a prediction about a
stock that everyone knew about in 2014
that everyone was buying that everyone
was speculating would go to the Moon and
yet now she's some kind of a genius Elon
Musk roughly around 2008 to 2010 he
became very wellknown especially Tesla
became very welln and then he decideed
to go public as a company and after he
went public in 2010 there have probably
been millions of investors either
directly or indirectly through funds
that have invested into Tesla it's
probably been one of the most
well-covered and and sort of like
mainstream company to talk about since
uh since they went public like even in
my case I had my dad put his entire life
savings into to Tesla since 2013 and it
wasn't because I was this lone sort of
wolf that figured this out there's
millions of investors who were fully
bought into Tesla way before Cathy wood
created Ark so the fact that she came in
and said that she's the genius that
found Tesla when there's been so many
investors into Tesla and it's been a
mainstream company to invest into for so
long is the thing that really shocks me
the fact that people even believe that
is sort of beyond my comprehension I
guess Arvis that should have created his
own Innovation fund too but regardless
Kathy would take this new found proof in
her skills to get the masses to cough up
around $50 billion of their money in
assets under management and you got to
give it to her she is a Smart Cookie
thing that she's done well is just
Market herself extremely well as this
sort of wise old person who is the
Pioneer of finding Innovative companies
but also some sort of Old Sage expert in
knowing what real traditional investment
is so she's played this role really well
and funny enough the one thing she did
learn from Elon Musk is how to Market
herself as some genius and then she just
rents and repeat because what she did
was primarily say that you should invest
into companies that make no money and
they have some magical dream of the
future and so the angle is this is like
hey look at all these old large
companies that are worth billions of
dollars uh clearly they have to get
replaced by the Innovative new Young
companies and I'm going to be some
genius who finds these Innovative
companies in truth all that's going on
is there's a random group of small
companies that have beautiful pipe
dreams for the future they have no idea
how to really run businesses and they
try their best uh to create Technologies
99% of the time it never really works
out and once you have the masses money
it's time to sit back relax and collect
your
fees Kathy charges around a 0.75
management fee on ref funds and on the
surface to the average Club 0.75% seems
like nothing a small number of course
she charges fees you got to pay the wise
old lady something but that is the trick
these fees are meant to appear small
when in reality if she had $50 billion
under management like she did at the
peak no matter if her funds go up or
crashes she is going to collect $375
million every year like clockwork over a
third of a billion dollars every year
for what buying stocks that any of us
can buy in Robin Hood putting together
pretty purple charts and PowerPoint in
her well research reports to pay for her
super sophisticated team of tech experts
that have never worked a day in Tech
according to her LinkedIn in 2021 once
again arv went through her team's
LinkedIn in 2021 has the leader Kathy
spent one day working in Tech or science
in her entire life no what about Tom her
Chief Operating Officer and the
president of Arc ctfs not at all leading
Arc is actually his first real job out
of college and back when he was in
college he spent most of his time as a
salesperson for a local TV station and
as a college sports announcer
impressively he also spent a few months
doing some tax accounting work and was
on the board of a club in college such a
techwiz huh what about her Tesla genius
Tasha keini has she ever accomplished or
built anything in Tech again not at all
she did some research internships and
assistant jobs during college and then
worked for a tiny little consulting firm
where her job description included sales
cold calling and communicating operating
expenses hm if you keep going with this
you'll quickly find that pretty much
every single person at AR invest does
not have a single clue about what
they're talking about when it comes to
science technology or any form of
innovation what they're good at is
marketing their pretty purple
PowerPoints but it didn't matter every
year the best performing asset class
randomly changes one year it will be
tech stocks one year it will be REITs
the next year it will be gold or bonds
and this time around with Kathy Wood it
happened to be Tech dos it randomly
happened to be Kathy Woods time to shine
and as Ark started blowing up as the
hype kept building on top of each other
it just became a self-reinforcing cycle
Arc went up so high because you guys
bought into it it's the same as any
Ponzi scheme really and so that's why
Ponzi schemes work is that if there's
good marketing people will invest into
the Ponzi scheme and the stocks that
she's investing into people will just
directly invest into those stocks too
and generally speaking you know everyone
will get excited because they think that
they figured it out and they see you
know graph going up but really it was
just your money fueling it was like a
self-fulfilling prophecy you know
everyone feels like it's a big hype they
pump up the stock that way but then as
soon as the fundamentals kick in which
is that the economy you know even
slightly adjusts into the negative then
reality hits the fan and they quickly
see that these companies aren't going to
ever make any money and these were
terrible companies to begin with so
everyone floods to take their money out
at the same time as AR said when it
comes to this type of scheme all it
takes is just one Tiny correction for it
to all come tumbling down and lucky for
C it didn't matter cuz you already
pocketed your
[Music]
fees The Genius of Kathy Wood is that
when it did come tumbling down no one
blamed her at the heart of it she is
stealing money because even though you
know her investors are losing billions
of dollars she gets to collect her
management fees and that's that
beautiful little ETF structure that she
created which is hey like just you know
even if you have a small amount of money
even if you're poor hand me your money
and I promise I'll make you rich but if
I don't make you rich then you know I
get to go home at night Rich myself and
that's what happened with Gerald Sai you
know he made off as a billionaire to the
best of my knowledge and same thing with
Janice you know the The Firm made
billions of dollars they didn't face any
consequences really and she has has has
made more money actually than most
billionaires that I know in terms of
real personal income and she's faced no
consequences for doing so so by having
the structure where it's just this
management fee it's it's not you know
she's presenting it as if she didn't
just steal your money but she absolutely
stole your money which is at the heart
of what's really
[Music]
happening here's the thing statistically
with how long Kathy was in the finest
game this was bound to happen sooner or
later qu from our side of the table none
of this is shocking about Kathy Wood
I've seen this movie before end quotes
said Carson block an investor who is
known for exposing corporate frauds well
it's not that you were really that
brilliant you were just long End quotes
as shown by her less than 1% return
10-year track record she was just in the
game long enough to get lucky and this
is how all of W Street is by the way
Kathy's operation was just really
impressive they brag about it like they
love the fact that they somehow tricked
people and that's why I I stay very far
away from from that industry after after
being exposed to what these people are
like and I would just never honestly
there isn't a single person who is a
public figure in the investment space
that that I would ever say is is
remotely even 1% trustworthy um their
entire private obsession is how to steal
money from people and that's the culture
of Wall Street I have never played Wall
Street the stock market itself cuz to me
Jordan it feels like it's just a casino
The House Always Wins is it is it that
or not it's worse than that it's it's a
corrupt Casino in a regular Casino the
ODS are stacked against you you know by
a small percentage some games they're
very close but the house might have a 3%
or 7% Edge but imagine if you go into a
casino where the dice are also loaded
against you so not only are the odds
against you by the nature of the game
but then the dice are loaded against you
where the Blackjack deal is dealing from
the bottom then you have no shot of
winning and unlike the generous like
Elizabeth Holmes or SBF these Wall
Street frosters will always get away
with it and they get away with it
because they have this Vibe really more
than anything else that they're
sophisticated and they're
well-intentioned and they talk about
corporations and they talk about um
annual reports and earnings and stuff to
make the regular person feel like
there's a science to it but honestly
everything that they're saying is
nonsense you know they don't even
understand a single thing about any
about any business most of them have
never created a real business in their
life they have no idea what they're
talking about and they don't even
understand anything about accounting
like when I actually dive into
accounting with any of these people who
claim to be some sort of geniuses in
finance they don't really understand you
know their left hand from the right hand
they're just really good at marketing
it's a very well-known fact um that
stock picking is uh just doesn't work
period and it's been proven
scientifically so many times now and uh
there is a you know famous example with
monkey picking stocks better than most
you know professional investment fund
managers and it's totally true you know
nobody in Wall Street thinks that you
can actually pick stocks and get rich
except if you're doing insider trading
insider trading actually works you know
that's why it's illegal um but uh
outside of insider trading there is no
way that you're going to you know pick
these sort of stocks consistently over
many years any better than a monkey
throwing darts I came across a quote
from The Economist Burton malel the
author of a random walk down Wall Street
he said a blindfolded monkey throwing
darts at a newspaper's financial page
could select a portfolio that would do
just as well as one carefully selected
by experts the motive behind such a
crass remark was to emphasize that not
even the most intelligent investors can
consistently beat the market so if a
monkey is able to replicate the same job
as some of the most educated
Professionals in the world then that's
something to
consider
so why don't all of us recognize that
people like Kathy are frosters simple
it's because these wall shoot types have
mastered the art of making it feel like
you didn't get scammed when in fact you
definitely got scammed losing other
people's money to such a dramatic degree
and they suffer no consequences those
are the genius fraudsters like in that
way she is a genius in my opinion at the
heart of it you know most people think
that she is somebody who had really good
intentions and she's now sad in the same
way that you're sad that things didn't
work out that's absolutely not the case
in my opinion she made out actually
making more money than most billionaires
in terms of true income and she lost you
know the the money of her investors in
the tune of probably tens of billions of
dollars and at the end of the day the
question is you know do you feel like
you were tricked or not that's at the
heart of it you know is it was she
scheming this thing the whole time was
she very conscious of what she was doing
and based on the fact that she
exclusively hired these young marketers
and no real scientists and no real you
know technology experts or no real
investment experts that to me speaks
volumes that this whole time you know
she was very aware of what she was doing
she was very opportunistic and seeing
that there was a new crowd of young
investors and she hasn't been getting
into trouble simply because the vibe
that she gave off the whole time is that
she was well-intentioned and now it
looks like Kathy Wood is trying to run
her scam all over again despite
everything that's happened now that it's
been a while since Arc crashed and
everyone kind of forgot about her
misdeeds she's now back on the news
making TV appearances again she's making
super bold predictions again and somehow
the news is getting filled with positive
stories about Ark talk about these ETFs
and then I want to go Broad and and sort
of get your sense of where the market is
and where crypto is going and what's
happening here but but tell us about
these ETFs specifically and what
there're what you're trying to do yes uh
with our partner 21 shares uh which is
the largest crypto ETP provider in the
world mainly European focused um we are
launching five uh ET F like this one
Kathy Wood just had her best month ever
so the masses are starting to trust
Kathy Wood again in November 2023
despite all the money Kathy has lost she
red in another $150 million in
Investments for Ark maybe an arc 2.0
comeback really is on the horizon she's
now even targeting the poor Europeans s
they a fresh new segment of the
population that hasn't got to experience
how wonderful it is to invest with Kathy
Kathy Wood says she's aiming for
European investors but at the end of the
day it will be the same Playbook she'll
wait for tech stocks to store again
which it randomly will she'll say she's
a genius again everyone will YOLO in and
once the economy tumbles just a tiny bit
again Ark will crash and she'll walk
away with another $250 million or
something and that is why we're making
this video to warn you that when you
hear that Kathy Wood is back or that
there's this new genius investor with
this new fund you know to take your
money and run for the hills and the
worst part is that these genius investor
types make people feel insecure about
themselves I wish I was a Genius Like
Her She's So Sophisticated I'll never be
smart like that when in reality behind
closed doors these people are no smarter
than you and I they're just more sick in
the head so you know at the heart of it
these public figures who kind of get
away with with what they're doing I
don't think that people should be
idolizing them because at the heart of
it it makes you feel like your own life
isn't as good as theirs and all they did
was sort of trick the public and so I
know plenty of these people now
privately I think you know pretty much
every billionaire in the world I'm
connected to either directly or through
one degree of connection away and not
one person really has a life that you
would want for yourself and the type of
people that they are I've never really
met billionaires that you know I would
ever want you know their lifestyle so
basically I relaunched my YouTube
channel and I want to make it a focus
for people to realize that number one
you don't need to idolize these people
and I'll walk you through exactly what
they really did uh to make their money
and and why you would never want to do
it but then number two there are so many
people who ethically actually make money
whether it's the local tutor or plumber
or any of these people that are actually
in servitude to society they are if they
do a really good job and they really
know how to grow their business they're
actually able to make plenty of personal
income without hurting anybody in the
process so that's the thing that I want
to focus on in terms of any of the
trainings that I provide is exactly what
can you do to you know grow your income
if you want to but in a way where you're
happy with yourself and people are
genuinely happy with you and exactly
what these people who everyone idolizes
like what is really going on behind the
scenes and I don't have any investment
firm I don't have any sort of
Corporation where I need investor I'm
simply somebody who's here to to expose
everything that I can and provide direct
training into exactly how to grow your
income in a way that you're really happy
with yourself and people are genuinely
happy with you long term Arvid recently
put out a free 1-hour training on his
YouTube channel that goes super super
deep into this exact strategy that he
recommends if you want to multiply your
income and you have a 95 job or your
self-employed or a solopreneur I've
listened to it and I was shocked at how
thoroughly he thought through every
single little thing and it's by far one
of the best most thorough business
trainings I've ever gone through and
it's completely free so click the card
on the screen or click the link below to
watch now Arvid has been my business
adviser for years he's the one who
taught me how to scale this channel so I
can't recommend him enough and if you're
interested in taking a one-on-one call
with him afterwards you can book a call
with the link in the description of that
video so click the card on the screen or
click the link below to watch
now